am abend des 13 januar 2012 startet die
costa concordia ihre rundfahrt durchs
westliche mittelmeer mehr als 3000
urlauber freuen sich auf eine
unbeschwerte zeit die je endet
angefangen und relativ schnell war es
dann so dass man irgendwie so ein
kleiner ruck gemerkt hat aber jetzt
nicht so auffällig was nur gleich
aufgefallen ist dass der vorrang ein
paar grad schief dahin ist knallte
und wir gucken uns an
und dann kam auch schon das porzellan
irgendwie entgegen es ist 21 uhr 45 und
sieben sekunden
das schiff hat einen felsen vor der
insel die leo gerammt er reißt einen 70
meter langen riss in den rumpf die
maschinenräume geflutet die concordia
manövrierunfähig das schiff in
schräglage doch statt sofortige
evakuierung zunächst beruhigende worte
[Musik]
erst über eine stunde nach dem unfall
der überfällige befehl das schiff zu
verlassen christina hammer erreicht ein
rettungsboot was ihr aber nicht hilft es
hat sich verkeilt durch das immer
heftigere abkippen der concordia und als
wir da wieder raus mussten weil das
nicht unterging da kriegt man richtig
angst also da war der zeitpunkt gekommen
wo man sagt ich hoffe ich komme so
herunter das muss man sich einfach mal
vorstellen das soll
im kino die verneigung heißt
absurderweise das manöver dass die
katastrophe der concordia erst
heraufbeschwört dabei fahren schiffe
möglichst nah an küstenorte heran um zu
grüßen der kapitän francesco es gibt
dino ist in dieser nacht verantwortlich
dafür ist längst von bord lange bevor
die evakuierung abgeschlossen ist das
kino erklärt sich in der nacht über funk
gegenüber dem dienst chef der
küstenwache ich würde ja gerne
zurückgehen ist ihnen klar dass es hier
dunkel ist und man nicht sieht
seit einer stunde sagen sie immer
dasselbe gehen sie jetzt an bord das ist
ein befehl
der kapitän folgte befehl nicht andere
helfen wie viel zu spät informiert
wurden die küstenwache das militär die
fähren von chili ring die menschen nach
und nach auf die insel wo die anwohner
alles tun um zu helfen
auch für tobias frasch und seine freunde
wir haben dann mit decke bekommen das
war wahrscheinlich eine ältere
tischdecke vom tisch die hatte zwar dann
auch ein brandloch aber das war es nur
in selb natürlich egal haben uns ein
bisschen zu denken können und
wir haben dann einfach gewartet was
passiert das herz erwärmen in dieser
nacht war vielleicht dass man leute in
wild zusammengewürfelter kleidung
gesehen hat in schulen etwa die
überhaupt nicht zu den menschen passten
die menschen von geely haben also nicht
nur ihre türen sondern auch ihre
kleiderschränke geöffnet
am tag nach der katastrophe müssen die
schiffbrüchigen für eine kurze überfahrt
wieder aufs mehrere ein weiterer schock
moment erinnert sich der bürgermeister
viele wussten überhaupt nicht dass sie
auf einer insel waren sie dachten sie
wären schon auf dem festland und müssten
nur noch ein taxi nehmen um nach hause
zu kommen die harte realität war aber
sie mussten wieder auf ein boot
an der costa concordia beginnt für die
einsatzkräfte währenddessen ein kampf
gegen die zeit denn es sind immer noch
menschen im schiffswrack auch
rettungstaucher suchen nach ihnen
ein besatzungsmitglied und ein pärchen
aus korea können noch lebend geborgen
werden
danach sind es nur noch tote
am ende fordert die havarie 32
menschenleben
für die italienische justiz gibt es
genau einen hauptschuldigen kapitän
francesco totti der sich selbst nur als
sündenbock sieht
bei diesem unfall habe ich so gehandelt
wie mein gewissen es mir gesagt hat das
ist keine straftat es ist ein unfall
das war natürlich schon sehr
enttäuschend dass man gemerkt hat dass
der kapitän ja einfach nicht das gemacht
hat was er machen muss vor allem im
sommer muss lisa zion bin eigentlich
fest davon überzeugt wenn der kapitän
und er ist offizier auf jeden fall von
anfang an gesagt hätte havarie wir
müssen runter dann wäre meiner ansicht
nach keiner gestorben das verfahren
gegen ski kino gibt durch alle instanzen
dauert von 2013 bis 2017 kino wird
verurteilt unter anderem wegen
mehrfacher fahrlässiger tötung
zurücklassen hilfsbedürftiger
herbeiführung einer havarie am ende
stehen 16 jahre haft
ich glaube dass der gerechtigkeit genüge
getan wurde und das ist im fall der
concordia tragödie ein element das
wirklich besonders wichtig war bei
der bewältigung des traumas hilft auch
dass das wrack vor giulio kein ewiges
mahnmal bleibt 20 monate nach der
katastrophe wird wahr was eigentlich
unmöglich schien
114.000 tonnen schiff gehen wieder in
die senkrechte und bleiben dabei in
einem stück die beispiellose operation
dauert 19 stunden
[Musik]
was ihr folgt sind grenzenloser jubel
und tiefe dankbarkeit gegenüber den mann
der diesen moment erst möglich gemacht
hat im kontrollraum haben alle
geklatscht und als ich über funk
weitergegeben habe sie ist sicher
aufgerichtet ohne die geringste
abweichung konnte ich hören wie alle
schrien und die schiffssirenen losgingen
das war schon was besonderes
das schiff gut jetzt auf einer
unterirdischen plattform für zehn monate
lang stabilisiert und gesichert
und kann schliesslich gehoben werden
unterstützt von riesigen schwimmkörper
die letzte fahrt der costa concordia
geht nach genua zum abwracken
am 23 juli 2014 ist getrennt was
getrennt gehört die leos wieder ganz bei
sich selbst zumindest fast
die costa concordia als teil von uns
allen holen die leute sagen wir kommen
vielleicht wegen des jahrestages jetzt
zum letzten mal auf die titelseite der
forderung aber die ganze geschichte
bewegt bis heute jeden hier in seinem
tiefsten
[Musik]
ich bin sehr stolz darauf was unsere
gemeinschaft in der unglücksnacht
geleistet hat in einer spontanen geste
der unterstützung und des willkommens
gegenüber den schiffbrüchigen die in
diesem moment eindeutig verloren
eine laune der natur ist vielleicht die
allergrößte besonderheit am unglück der
concordia der günstig stehende wind aus
nordost nun ihm ist es zu verdanken dass
das schiff überhaupt in richtung insel
gedrückt wurde hätte er anders gestanden
wäre die concordia womöglich im offenen
meer gesunken bei mehreren hundert
metern tiefe
ja von meinem hartmann war es klar die
macht keine kreuzfahrt gehen wenn es war
für sie ihre erste kreuzfahrt ist ein
erlebnis kann das verstehen ich habe nur
dankbar dass ich ohne größere blessuren
darunter gekommen bin das muss ich
ehrlich
nach dem zehnten jahrestag des unglücks
wird es wieder ruhiger werden um die
geschichte der concordia für die die
damals dabei waren bleibt sie aber für
immer mehr als bloß seine langsam
verblassende erinnerung